thank you very much I think you're
you're in the Christmas spirit are you
in the is that what this is I am I think
everybody is I I tell you yesterday I
found my elf on a shelf passed out next
to my vape
pen something's going up but uh and it's
Hanukkah how many celebrating Han all
right so those people uh you know those
people like in the midwest who don't
know no I'm
kidding there's Jews everywhere
endangered everywhere but they're
everywhere uh but uh Hanukkah is
celebrat a festival celebrating the Jews
recovery of the city of Jerusalem in the
2 Century before Christ or is the
Palestinians say get off our
land oh that
issue that issue is not going away did
you see what happened with the college
presidents this week the presidents of
the of Harvard Harvard University and
upen and MIT were hauled before
Congress uh and yelled at for good
reason uh for refusing to call the
genocide of Jews on campus bullying or
harassment misgendering a Jew get thrown
off for that in the
minute that's not the other
thing
uh
so and there may be protests here this
weekend because the president is in town
isn't that great when the president
no really you think that's
good are you out on
the I'll say
this the only other time in this town an
81y old up traffic is when they're
driving a white Camry in the passing
land no it's not good when the
president's
here but the the Republicans had another
one of their debates without Trump this
is getting
now there's four of them left on the
island and
and it's just sad it's like a battle of
the bands between the other women in
Destiny's
Child and the
uh and the surviving members of The
Doors you know it's
just but no there is some crazy
right-wing out there I got to tell
you this State of New Hampshire is
proposing a ban on abortion that starts
at 15 days after gestation you're not
even pregnant yet 15 days not weeks days
and they asked the author of this bill
what what were you thinking and he said
I don't know I never got past second
base